yay another Zucco episode oh boy another
really nice one um this is the Western
air temple and first of all this temple
looks great I love the idea of having it
all under a cliff and having it all
upside down but it still functions it's
still even though the temples are built
upside down you can still you can still
like the beds are right side up and the
chairs and so on so forth um so I love
that design just another really original
clever design and this is pretty much
the episode where Zuko tells the group
he wants to join them he wants to be on
their side and he wants to help defeat
the Fire Lord I love the fact that he's
not very good at telling them and he
rehearses on this frog which is very
funny
um I mean the reveal that's a frog we
know he's magic gonna be talking to the
group first but the actual words he
chooses are very very funny
um again great voice work from everybody
you know again Dante Bosco he's so
awesome doing this um you know he can
sell comedy very well just as well as
the drama and I like the fact the group
does not it's kind of hobbies are not
gonna accept him right away and they're
gonna have to go through something to
finally accept him but I like that it
takes the full episode it's not like
half the episode uh it takes a while and
I like even then they're not all on
board I like the fact that Katara
particularly is very angry and she
completely has the right to be because
she became probably the most vulnerable
around him and believed him the most and
feels that she was not just betrayed but
lie too she doesn't think that what he
was saying now is truthful and that it
was a trick and she'll go along with
hang on this I'm letting him into the
group but she makes it very clear she
does not like it and if anything goes
wrong you know his ass is grass
so I like that I like that they don't
all just sort of accept him Sokka isn't
really sure Toph I think is sure enough
you know but sort of doesn't carry
either way I think
to say I can whatever hit him with a
boulder or something uh and on top of
that we finally see the end of
sparky-sparky boom man or whatever he
was called um yeah I love that line -
when Zuko chicer says that's not his
name but yes - just be a good comedy in
this goods are tragic comedy uh and we
get more of actually I'm shocked there
wasn't more of the other kid characters
and this like we sort of see them go off
and do their own thing but if they
weren't sir called in on the discussion
you know which made me understand it sir
comes down to the fourth and they're
sort of the leaders of the group now um
uh those I guess it adds up and I like
that Aang says I'm not gonna say yes
until I'm sure that my my group is
behind this uh which I really like I
like the way how he comes to the
conclusion that he should be allowed and
how he should be the firebender that
teaches him how he has also let it get
to him the mistake of with his power and
he understands the responsibility more
so I really appreciate that a ban
against are those interesting parallels
going for whatever reason I I don't know
why I did not put together that he was
gonna be the one to teach firebending I
don't know it seems very obvious but for
some reason I didn't put that together
so when they're saying you have to learn
firebending but who's gonna teach him
I'm like oh yeah I don't know why that
took me so long to figure out it is
pretty friggin obvious but um what else
what else
yeah it just and of course anything to
make just throw more crap on Zuko and
just have the angst builded him being
tortured a I just when Tom comes in a
throws the fire in birds or fish oh
sorry that great life is Wi-Fi so bad at
being good it's I just love it um oh
what's the other element I'm missing
here um they get to the air temple there
died I can't think my mind's blanking
and the clock is ticking yeah it
I'll do an edit I remember now
it's the denial
and egg has at the beginning I thought
was very interesting because I was
saying the last one I'll be fascinated
to see how he kind of deals with this
sort of second failure the second chance
that was botched and he clearly he's in
a state of denial come on let's go
flying let's do this let's I mean it
seems like that pain has really hit so
close to home that's like it can't even
comprehend it so he sort of puts it out
of his mind for a bit and hey let's go
play we're gonna have fun I would have
liked of those dealt with a little bit
more but again this is sore as you go
story and I understand that it's I'm
curious if they're gonna go into that
more I would like them to but we'll see
what happens I mean again that's a
second failure and it you could even
argue that's harder than the first
failure so I'd like to see a little bit
more a little bit more diving into that
but uh you know again we'll see where
that goes
um so yeah not too much else I also like
that again keeping in continuity that
Appa remembers they set him free and so
he treats them very kindly and licks him
and stab yeah I think that was a very
and that was also a clever way of sort
segue into hey maybe we should have him
around me maybe this makes sense uh so
yeah it can't think of too much else for
this episode just a another great Zuko
episode I'm really happy days part of
this group I I love the way this has
really come full circle that they
started off you know so very similar
than they sort of split apart now
they're coming back together again I
just I love the way that works out
I think it's obvious at some point Zuko
is gonna win katara over but it might be
a while and again I like that it's not
so easy it's that was as he put it that
was a betrayal that he as she said you
he made his choice and he has to live
with it and they're more doing it out of
the fact that they have no choice in
this and they need Aang to learn
firebending and here's someone that not
only understands the craft but he
understands the responsibilities of it
now so it it's a good it's a really
really good mesh and I I really like
this one again it's a any sort of Zuko
transformation any bit where Zuko is
trying to be good and trying to make
that transition I really really like um
the a thing that really dives into is uh
any kind of transformation with them I
really adore so um yeah there you go
another great episode and the next one
is coming your way